i want to start by putting this in
perspective in terms of the loss of
human life you say that climate change
will be many times or could be many
times more deadly than the cova 19
pandemic make that connection for us how
much worse could it be yeah so the
deaths will just go up over time as you
get more heat waves
forest fires and most importantly the
inability to go outdoors and do farming
anywhere near the equator and so it'll
it'll get worse and worse
the temperature rise is based on the
total
cumulative amount of co2 we put in the
atmosphere
and so certainly by the end of the syst
the century
uh you'll have permanent die-offs of all
these coral ecosystems you no beach you
ever went to will be
around uh and sadly there won't be a
simple solution like hey let's get a
vaccine and we can get ourselves out of
this thing because it's the entire
industrial economy that's responsible
for these emissions
now you say we have no choice but to get
to zero from 51 billion tons a year and
i know you're optimistic you say it'll
be hard but i want to hear from bill
gates the realist like how likely is it
that we get to zero is there a
percentage you can give me
well unless the younger generation
adopts this as the moral cause that's
important to them beyond their
individual success
and they're very loud about that uh in
all the rich countries and you know
across multiple political parties unless
we have that that's always putting it
first on the agenda
then i don't think we'll meet 2050 but i
do see signs that that's you know coming
into place i mean you know what cause
could be more important than preserving
livability
uh of the earth and these natural
ecosystems so my role was simply to say
yes this goal is a good one although
very very hard and then talk about how
we accelerate the innovation
uh and make people realize that
it because we're trying to get to zero
it's every sector of a mission and
there's been a tendency to focus on two
of the five electricity and transport
but kind of ignore
agriculture and buildings and then
manufacturing
including cement and steel so it's a
it's hopefully a dose of realism for
anyone who thought it was easy but also
a road map
uh to help people who think it's
impossible to see that it is possible
now you mentioned 2050 there uh we hear
a lot of dates john kerry said we have
nine years left the u.n said we have 10
years left back in 1989 and i wonder
what is the actual goal post and are
these dates a
distraction uh well 2050 is probably the
soonest that we could get emissions near
to zero and so that's where that that
date comes from
the more you force up the temperature
the more you get sea level rise the more
you get left we don't know some magic
number where
you know it's dramatically worse it
so you know it just it's bad the more it
warms up
and uh for subsistence farmers you know
they've already seen it we see we see
events in the u.s
uh including you know weirdly because
they call it warming the ability of cold
fronts to come in and cause disaster all
of the
extreme things get
more likely
and you know i think that's creating an
awareness
um
but you know i wish we could get it done
before 2050 that's that's you know
there's just too much to replace the
next 10 years we have to do a lot of
invention
uh because when you're talking about all
sorts of steel and cement factories
scaling up deployment globally will take
the those next 20 years so let's talk
about the inventions you've been looking
for solutions that have unbelievable
scale and reliability funding some of
those through gates ventures over the
last 13 years
where should investors be placing their
bets right now
well this is going to change a lot of
industries you know the car industry
and you've got people like gm saying
after 2035 they won't make
uh gasoline cars uh all these
manufacturing businesses uh will have to
change their processes
you know i put about two billion in uh
to a variety of things you know and and
i'm
uh
both directly and indirectly through
breakthrough energy ventures that i
created uh trying to make sure there's
high-risk capital for every area of
emission in fact backing
a number of companies in each area
because the failure rate will be fairly
high
but
you know there's there's promising work
we talk about the green premium which is
the extra cost to buy say a ton of green
cement versus the normal cement those
green premiums are very very high
and i propose in the book that the size
of those metrics and bringing those down
to be very very small
that that's actually the best indication
uh will the world be able to achieve
this very ambitious goal even more than
the near-term reductions because you can
make near-term reductions and not solve
the hard parts
uh
and we need all the parts now so much of
the problem involves big things as you
point out like steel and cement and
fertilizer and i wonder how much do
individuals and individual decisions
really matter like if i stop eating
burgers which you point out are a big
carbon culprit will that really make a
difference
well
yes your carbon footprint will go down
dramatically if you don't eat meat
but
one way to do that is to be a customer
some portion of the time of these new
ways of making ground beef that people
like beyond and impossible and others
are bringing out because as demand for
those goes up they scale up their
factories they improve the quality uh
they get the price come down so whether
it's an electric car or
uh artificial burger uh that that demand
is catalytic because we're trying to
recreate what we saw with solar panels
and lithium-ion batteries where the the
volume actually brought the cost down
and you know for the passenger car
and within 10 to 15 years all these
improvements will mean the green premium
the extra
uh what you give up with an electric car
where you might need a tax credit
that'll go all the way to zero and the
market
uh as you saw with gm's plans
will be green without
the government having to impose
regulations or tax credits but those
things are so key to help us get to that
end state
now
we know you love burgers and i'm just
curious like what do you do
when you get a craving
you know how often can you just not
resist and
you just
eat a good old-fashioned burger
well i about 50 of the time when i have
a burger it's one that's made with these
impossible foods or beyond meat uh
ground beef and those have essentially
no
uh greenhouse gas emissions as they
improve their products uh and they're
quite good i really highly recommend
that people try those uh i'll get to the
point where i'm 100
uh buying uh just those burgers i'm also
spending money on
director capture and
lots of things to completely offset
my carbon footprint which you know it's
very high because of the way i i travel
and you know i have more than one house
so you know i'm in a sense one of the
most guilty but i'm
uh pioneering
uh offset approaches that are are really
honest and that uh as those get
purchased they'll also come down in
price so you're planning to give me it
up 100
uh the
the cow-based meat uh
now you know some people are trying to
change the cow's diet or capture the
methane so you know we wouldn't i don't
want to count the cow out there's a lot
of uh ingenuity there but right now
these protein-based approaches
uh have surprised me how far they've
come in when they've been offered in
burger chains
the demand has been quite good
now some of the critics have said you
don't focus on the political obstacles
enough when it comes to climate change
you're solely focusing on the technology
here if there's one thing that the biden
administration could do to help solve
this problem faster that would really
make a difference what would that one
thing be
well the long lead time item to drive
innovation is r d
funded by the government and in the
health space uh the us has done a
brilliant job with the national
institute of health that's driven
breakthroughs and you know creates
private companies that take that and
offer products
uh to the us into the world the energy r
d budget is
way too small well below the health
levels so i you know that's got to go up
dramatically
uh some of the tax credits to help the
new product categories like green steel
and cement or energy storage uh we need
to apply that tactic there and then the
government's a big purchaser uh and you
know they can buy more
uh of these green products
and
you know so we really need to get going
uh
uh and push the innovation and push the
demand side for those innovations as
well
now we just saw a major shock to the
electric grid in texas a lot of deaths
you mentioned that energy plants there
should have been weatherized and i'm
curious
where do you think we should be making
investments right now before this
happens again
well there's two things the texas event
chose and one thing it doesn't uh it
doesn't show that
renewables were the problem in that case
uh because
uh
there were shutdowns uh because of lack
of weatherization in natural gas and
even uh tripping one reactor to go off
but the two things it does show us that
we're going to have more extreme events
so we need to be ready for that
and we need to invest in resilience it
is fair to say that
if you don't build transmission and
storage and
some
nuclear which is not weather dependent
uh that you are going to have uh a lack
of reliability when there's tough
weather and you know the politics of
permitting uh
transmission lines and we need to come
up with a way to make that more
attractive
uh so you know there's a legitimate
issue
uh
of of reliability although it wasn't uh
the problem in this case
now your fellow tech titans like jeff
bezos and mark zuckerberg and elon musk
they're all tackling different elements
of the climate crisis and i'm wondering
if you should all join forces like the
climate avengers or something to to
really take this on
well elon uh you know tesla pioneered
the electric car market which is great
his carbon challenge uh for direct air
capture will be good uh jeff bezos has
made a gigantic commitment with his
climate fund and actually i am talking
to him we'll we will end up doing some
things in partnership and at least we'll
see understand
what the other one is up to so i agree
as we get more people engaged
uh you know figuring out okay what is
the path for innovation both supplying
and demanding innovation we we should we
should brainstorm more although you know
our individual ideas are part of the
strength of you know crazy entrepreneurs
working on this problem
how might we see you partnering with
jeff bezos
uh well he's funded a lot of the key
climate organizations
uh
you know we're talking about uh and he's
part of breakthrough energy ventures uh
the idea of how you create a demand side
for these green products even in the
early stage where their green premium
will be high
uh that's an area where you know we need
something i've realized of all the
missing pieces
uh and we talked about that as as being
catalytic in nature we want to bring
companies
and governments in on that but having a
strong base of philanthropic capital to
get it started would would be fantastic
and yet you know jeff bezos obviously
has made that 10 billion dollar
commitment but these amazon cardboard
boxes the blue and white envelopes i i
hear even worse the trucks for
delivery i mean shouldn't a company as
innovative as amazon be able to figure
that out
well that
you can't put every societal problem on
amazon uh
they are part of the physical economy
delivering goods so of course their
scope 3 emissions are large you know
they so there's amazon is a company
that's committed to electric delivery
vehicles and funding uh
innovation and then there's jeff as an
individual where that 10 billion uh is
even more than i've spent i've spent a
few billion and i'll spend a few billion
more uh in the years ahead so you know
in both cases i think you'll see uh
thoughtful ways of spending the money
but
this requires
you know all of society to to get
engaged it's not you know just one
intervention or one uh
you know company that that can fix this
so
meantime you know
you make it clear
technology is what's going to help us
solve this problem but at the same time
technology is what's also making the
problem worse in perpetuating
uh the you know
misinformation that climate change is a
hoax on social media how frustrating is
that for you well i'm not sure how much
i know in the case the pandemic there's
a lot of crazy conspiracy things out
there and that
you know is widespread and affecting
mass use and openness to vaccination and
climate yes we're probably likely to get
that particularly as we succeed in
getting governments to you know have
aggressive policies
uh you know understanding why
some people don't see this problem or
feel a need to deny the problem uh i
think we have to be you know very
thoughtful about who will they trust
uh to be convinced you know you know who
could go out and look at these coral
reefs or you know look at the
heat wave or
uh you know what you know just look at
the model it shows that you know the
beaches in uh lots of places will be
gone
uh you know this is because it's a
multi-destiny task you know we being
shrill
may not be the the way to get going so
lots of education you know and that's
part of the goal of the book is to get
people talking
about wow you know if we were going to
commit
you know we there should be a real plan
not just you know things that
seem affected like you know divesting
this stock or that stock and which is a
fine thing to do if people feel uh like
that but it's not
to actually reduce the emissions you
have to change the way you make steel
there's just no kind of metric or
divestment or
you know blocking traffic that alone
will get rid of those emissions
so you've never just wanted to pick up
the phone and call mark zuckerberg and
say
hey
this is really slowing me down
well mark uh
you know he's
you know he's got to maintain kind of an
open platform and
you know on vaccine things they've you
know
stepped up to try and get the egregious
stuff out of there uh i have a good
dialogue with mark i think he's been put
in a hard position in terms of what the
government rules or what the company
should do to let
debate continue while you have the
really extreme stuff that drives people
uh into sort of a non-reality position
how do you distinguish those things and
who who's supposed to do that
you know when you have millions of
messages every hour
at the same time you recently said you
think trump should and eventually will
be let back on twitter why support that
when he spreads so much in
misinformation about issues like climate
and vaccines which you care about
well there's a question whether labeling
uh things is better i mean those
messages are likely to show up somewhere
you know it's a country with a first
amendment and so uh you know do you want
to have one party have one social
network and yeah party have another
social network you know this unlike
climate you know where i'm in talking to
the best scientists and finding it the
way we draw the boundaries on social
networking i don't have that solution
but i know that uh we need very smart
people
uh at facebook and universities uh
trying to say
where how do you draw the line there i
haven't seen a proposal where you go wow
if you do that then it's as open as it
needs to be and the crazy stuff goes
away and i i i
look at every idea uh so you know i
think this is a societal challenge
now while you're pouring money into
vaccines some of your peers are pouring
money into rockets and i'm curious do
you think earth will ever be more
uninhabitable than mars like is this
really what's going to save the human
race
well i i think we should preserve this
planet uh and make it hospitable to
human life uh the idea of mars or even
artificial planets you know it it's
great that other people are doing that
but i'm not involved in that i don't see
that
as part of the solution
uh
i don't think i'm missing something
there but you know you're talking about
you know when you're talking about elon
musk or or japisos they're in the
climate game
and in a constructive way which i'm at
least glad uh that they're putting some
of their resources
in this direction
so speaking of elon you've you said we
need hundreds of elon musks and with
tesla's expansion in places like china
and india
that's only going to increase their
carbon footprint should tesla be more
upfront about that
well tesla reduces your carbon footprint
and if they get
you know an electric car
uh
as we convert the electric generation to
b0 emissions
is one of the few categories that you
know we see a path to zero now it's only
about seven percent of emissions come
from
passenger cars globally and so you can't
declare victory there but
you know as the cost of those cars comes
down the range goes up the charge points
are more numerous and standardized and
quick charging
you'll you'll feel like yes a gasoline
car
less maintenance you know quieter
the market will eventually
take care of this and so you won't need
regulations even though they've been
used including a tax credit
to get the volume up
to get to that point and so
every category needs to go through that
process of bringing its its green
premium
down dramatically
now
i understand you own a porsche electric
car yourself um
[Music]
elon has in the past claimed you shorted
tesla and i wonder if there's any truth
to that
uh well
you know i think tesla's an amazing
company uh i wish i'd you know own been
more on the
alongside but you know i'm you know it's
it's great uh
and
you know i i have lots of relatives who
own teslas that i've uh helped buy for
them so you know nothing but positive
thoughts about tesla in its role
um now that said i i'm i'm curious for
your thoughts here because
tesla could potentially make more money
from its bitcoin investment this year
than profits from electric cars in all
of 2020.
what's your take on that what what's
your bitcoin take and
and the fact that the price can just go
up or down based on a simple tweet from
him
well
look elon has tons of money and he's
very sophisticated so you know i'm i
don't worry
that uh you know his bitcoin will sort
of randomly go up or down
i do think people get bought into these
manias who
may not have as much money to spare so
i'm not
uh bullish on bitcoin and you know my
general thought would be uh
that you know if you have less money
than elon you should probably uh watch
out
why aren't you bullish on bitcoin
it's it's look
there are things we invest in in society
that produce output uh
bitcoin happens to use a lot of energy
uh it happens to
promote not anonymous transactions
they're not reversible transactions
are the gates foundation does a lot in
terms of digital currency
but those are things where
you can see
who's making the transaction uh so
digital money is a good thing uh uh and
you know there's a different approach
that's local currency and attributed and
you know deals with all the money
laundering and terrorism type
regulations and yet gives you the very
com the convenience and the low cost of
transaction
uh and so you know our foundation is
very proud that in the pandemic a lot of
the countries we funded to do this were
able to get money out to their citizens
very very efficiently so that's
something that it's not got the
visibility of bitcoin but the move
towards digital money
uh that we're very engaged in is a super
positive thing uh that eventually will
get to even the poorest countries so
let's talk about the pandemic
obviously your other big focus in
addition to climate change the u.s just
hit 500 000 deaths and i just wanted to
take a moment there how does that number
strike you
well it's unbelievably it's
you know more than
any war we've been in except the civil
war uh you know it's enough that i'm
sure it's touched
almost everybody uh
you know we
we count on government to
both before something bad happens and
when something bad happens to
uh protect us and
it didn't work in this case uh so
hopefully it's a lesson going forward
about
investments in global health that
the u.s and the u.s cooperating with
other countries
need to get done
to be ready for the next pandemic
um how concerned are you about the new
variants and vaccines keeping up
well amazingly our foundation was
studying three vaccines and trials in
south africa when the variant showed up
and so we were able to gather uh
really detailed data
showing that you know they all still had
some beneficial effect uh but
particularly nova vaccine johnson and
johnson even though they work a little
less well we're still
a great tool there and
you know so weirdly the us didn't
sequence enough to see its variants like
the uk and even what we funded in south
africa now that's been remedied just
another miscue by
the country that should have done the
best job so
uh we'll get on top of the variants you
know we may need to tune the vaccines
all the manufacturers are looking
through how quickly
they could get that done it'll extend
it'll add to the transmission and deaths
but you know
if we get vaccination rates up only by
at most a month or two
are pfizer moderna johnson and johnson
doing enough to prioritize populations
in developing countries and what's the
ideal
shot for
the developing world
now the private sector including those
three companies did a a fantastic job
uh
our we've been backing the mrna approach
uh for about a decade now sadly it's not
that mature and so you can't scale it up
as much as we'd like nor is it cheap and
so the vaccines three through five astra
seneca johnson johnson and novavax can
be scaled up
through uh indian factories to a higher
degree so for developing countries those
three and
sending the right ones the right place
will be most of the solution
not to take away from anything that
pfizer who funded its work or moderna
did but those will mostly land in rich
countries
so at this point what are the biggest
headwinds that you see in the vaccine
manufacturing process
yeah well every day
there's a complex discussion about okay
what are you know do we have enough
glass vials for fill finish do we have
all these different ingredients
uh that come from different countries i
do think some of the you know
vaccine nationalism where
people are trying to look good in their
own country by
somewhat blocking things going around
that's
you know there's huge downside in that
uh
you know we need to get the vaccines out
in large numbers we need to end this
epidemic globally and from the beginning
the voice of the foundation is included
not only
moving faster but this equity question
and
uh over the next four or five months
the the world
can behave well it's mostly governments
now
uh that are limiting uh how much we can
help
um you know countries that don't have
vaccine factories